for michael b jordan the fourth of july
meant a whole lot of hanging with the
boys i'm just genuinely excited check
out michael looking fashionable as
always at the red white and bootsy
fourth of july party at nobu malibu mbj
was in good company fellow a-listers
kevin hart and jamie foxx were also at
the star-spangled soiree and the actor's
wide-eyed grin says it all an eyewitness
tells et he was having a great time and
was smiling and hanging out with a bunch
of guy friends he was mainly sticking to
his friend group and not flirting with
anyone he seemed like he was relaxed and
just enjoying the day it's cool man this
is cool michael's outing comes just
weeks after splitting from his
girlfriend of over a year lori harvey
yeah that was the duo in january all
smiles on the beach during a game of
football actually very funny a lot of
people don't know that about her yeah
she's really funny what makes your
relationship
so special
um you know we just really balance each
other and i really do believe in this
statement you know when they say when
you know you know
and i think that really applies to our
situation and you know we just have a
really good time together he's so sweet
very attentive you know he listens to me
you know the things that i say that i
want and he like really makes an effort
but by june a source confirmed to et
they'd gone their separate ways adding
they were both heartbroken and upset
as for why they split we're told they're
at different stages in their lives
[Laughter]
[Applause]
while michael's been out with the boys
lori's been busy too working on her
career over the holiday weekend she
attended the essence festival in new
orleans where she spoke on a panel about
being an entrepreneur as the owner of
skincare line skin by lori harvey but
she also made sure to take advantage of
the city's tasty treats
sharing these fun snaps enjoying some
authentic southern food
[Music]